[Music]
I just know it's a has an unbreakable
grip but I can't tell you what it is
it's just life empty without it
I have to say the people who really
impressed me when I have a chance to
meet them are people whose names nobody
will ever hear so for example in
southern coal well let me give you a
personal looks very personal example a
couple of months ago I learned that
extremely poor peasants in southern
Colombia whose lives are being destroyed
in part by us-run chemical warfare
called fumigation which destroys their
agricultural lands and communities and I
purchased by the terror of the Colombian
state and the by now terror the
guerrillas that they're caught in the
middle of really miserable people they
just planted a forest in memory of my
wife who died a couple of months ago
that's one of the most moving things
I've ever experienced I've actually met
some of them I did go down and couldn't
do my couldn't do anything for them I
just listened to horrible testimonies
but these are people with real and
they're all over the world you know with
real human feelings commitment concern
suffering beyond what we can imagine but
willing to do something for someone else
they've never met and I you find things
like that all over the place here to
some of us moving experiences I've had
are just in black churches in the South
during the civil rights movement where
you know people were getting beaten
killed really struggling for the most
elementary right just asking for the
resolute the Congressional amendments
during the civil war asking to be
implemented not particularly radical but
quite a battle
[Music]